can't tell if you can see me yet
there i am hello
good evening everyone
i'm waiting for some people to arrive
i thought i'd do a bit of a live stream
because it's been a while since last
time
i have a little chat with you guys have
some tea i have some tea here
just hang out for a few minutes
[Music]
let's see
hello so now people are starting to
arrive hello everyone
hope everyone is doing well
hey bilal
[Music]
denmark i've been to denmark once
but it's been a while too
yeah so t's yes i'm drinking some tea
here um
[Music]
i'm making some
so loose leaf tea
this is
a chinese it's called a kimonte which is
a black tea variety from china if any of
you are t nerds out there it's a mao
fung variety of kimon tea
which is very nice
so i'm gonna
let me just
let me just make some tea
and i can start answering your questions
also
so i hope you all liked the
video today i released a new video about
pythagoras
who is a
quite the character obviously
um
so far you guys really seem to be liking
the video so that's really
awesome
yes zara you can you can't drink coffee
that's okay i guess
i should just because i'm gonna i'm
gonna be making my tea and i'm gonna
forget to
to stop brewing it on time i'm gonna
put a timer on here
here we go
someone's asking about the music
equipment in the background um yes i am
planning to release some new music
actually
um as some of you might know i make all
the
music
not all of it but most of the music in
my videos
is made by me
and there's already
an ep out
on spotify and all these places called
desert wanderings which is
uh
a few tracks that i've used in the
background of some of the the the videos
and
this summer also probably will uh there
will be a full album coming out of new
tracks that i've made since
since that ep came out
is the volume low again
shouldn't be
let me check it's it's basically as
the microphone is as loud as i can
make it
um
what instruments do i play i play well
depends on what counts as what i play
i can sort of
i'm okay at various different
instruments but i'm not great at many of
them so i play guitar that's like my
main instrument i guess and also the aud
which is the arabic or well the middle
eastern loot
which originally comes from
uh older loots of course
they say it comes from perugia
originally an instrument called barabat
anyway i played that i played duduk
which is an armenian or anatolian
double-rated wind instrument
and then i play some
i can play bass i can play some basic
percussion some piano some
i have mandolin
i play a little bit i'm not very good at
it
[Music]
so i play a few different things but i
would say like guitar
would
those two are basically my main
instruments
and i i attempt to sing sometimes
although i'm not
all that successful at it
so here's the tea it's done
this is like i said it's a black tea
it's got a nice sort of light
brown color
i'm gonna wait until it cools off a bit
so
speaking of which the the
video that came out today on pythagoras
has some new music in it that i made
specifically for that video so if you
hear
in the background in the video
uh there's some new tracks in which i
try to evoke
sort of the ancient mediterranean
basically
it's it's similar to a lot of the stuff
that i do usually but but it's also
a bit more in that vein i was inspired
because recently i played a video game
called the forgotten city which came out
last year
and i really enjoyed that and i think
the music was
you know it wasn't something it wasn't
anything fancy but the music was really
cool and so i was inspired by that kind
of stuff
for the video and the intro to to the to
the video uh which is going to become
the sort of official intro to the series
about philosophy and religion in the
hellenic world
that is that i made that music as well
and that is based on
the so-called um
right which is
at least according to some the oldest
surviving piece of music or at least the
oldest surviving full
song
that has survived from antiquity and so
i took the basic melody from that and i
made that intro i think that turned out
pretty cool
so this should be okay by now
cheers everyone
so um
go ahead and go ahead and ask me some
questions i'll do my best to answer them
can you please bossa nova and no not
really
but i
[Music]
i would like to learn at some point
when are we going to do so areep or eric
asks when are we going to have a video
on ismailism it's coming soon i've
started writing that
i started writing that basically the
same time that i started writing the
video on on 12 irishism
and that's going to be part of the same
series essentially
where i go through different branches of
shiism so i started with 12 or sheism
i'm going to do ismailism next
and then probably i'm going to tackle
the zaidi's as well eventually i don't
know much about the zeides relatively
so i still need to do some research on
that
i have done some stuff on these smileys
in the past there are quite a lot of
videos about these smileys
um on my channel but i wanted to do like
a
similar to what i did on twelverism
recently doing like a big
video that goes through
like the the main
ideas and historical
developments of that
movement this mileism is fascinating on
so many levels uh
and i know it so
i've studied a smiley she is him a lot
more than twelver she isn't
so so writing the the episode on
twelverism was also really great uh
the way of discovering a lot of new
things about that tradition which i
thought was really cool
do i enjoy beans no of course not
they are destructive after all
whatever whatever that means
you introduced me to mahmoud shabby
study in surah habali did they have
changed my life uh
well
i'm glad you liked them as much as me i
think especially shabbishtari
the gulshani ras the the rose garden of
secrets
which is a work of sufi poetry that he
wrote
is just one of the most
wonderful things that has ever been
composed in that whole
tradition of sufism i think
it takes
the basic ideas of the school of ibn
arabi and just
expresses them in such beautiful poetic
ways
i wish i knew persian so i could read it
in
in the original language i won't read in
translation after all which in itself is
really beautiful that's what i've
experienced but i can only imagine what
it's like in in persian
samstone have you covered al-halaj yet
no well i have talked about halage on a
number of occasions he tends to pop up
when when one talks about sufism
you know some would argue you know
there's a debate whether he should be
counted as a sufi i think probably he
should but
you know there there's a debate about
what counts as sufi in the early periods
and sufis were a specific group that
were referred to by that name
but certainly he he fits into the wider
category of sufism so he pops up in that
discussion but i haven't made a video on
halage and i probably will at some point
because he's one of the central figures
in that whole in the history of sufism
so
rami
asks me is there any books you would
recommend to people interested in
getting into theology
that's an interesting that's a tough
question so that depends on what is
there a particular
branch of theology that you're
interested in is like islamic theology
because then there are some books like
very basic introductory books like the
oxford handbook to islamic theology i
think it's called or the cambridge
companion to islamic theology
i i would always advise people also to
read some original works some primary
sources
and in terms of theology there is some
great stuff um
again it depends on what you're
interested in right so if you want to
know like
sunni ashadi theology there is
a
you know you could read al qazali
that kind of thing
in terms of you know christian theology
i don't know much about secondary
sources devoted to christian theology in
particular there's there are similar
books like oxford handbook to christian
theology i think
but in terms of christian theologians
you have you know thomas aquinas
who is the main figure probably at least
in the catholic tradition
um
pseudo-dionysius is a is an amazing
primary source and one of the most
important figures in early christian
theology
and one of the pioneers of
what's called apophatic theology
which is this idea that god
you know a human
being can never understand or grasp what
god is we can only talk about god in
terms of what he is not this is
something that many later thinkers would
adopt like
you know maimonides for example who
i made a video collaboration on recently
he's he's also heavily apathetic
in that we can only say we can't say
that god is powerful
or we can't say that god has knowledge
because that's you know comparing him to
creatures we can only say that he is not
ignorant
right we can't say that he is
powerful
because again that's like a creature
equality we can only say that he's not
weak
that's the basics of apophatic theology
and it can go even deeper than that of
course and pseudodynesis is is
an amazing
early figure in that movement
and a christian theologian his main work
is called
the mystical theology i think there is a
translation of that work in the uh
classics of western spirituality series
basically all books in that series are
worth having they're all really really
good so this is a series of translations
of classical texts in in the western you
know how we define that with western uh
religious and spirit transition which
includes
uh you know christianity judaism islam
and sufism
um
like native american religions
and so on it's really cool series
okay let's see
can i have another sip of my tea here
so hadrian anton
would you enjoy making a video on
algelian and son of kamen
yeah maybe um he's certainly an
interesting figure
um
very important in the school of ibn
arabi
could make a video dedicated to him if
there's an interest he's not that famous
of a figure outside of a very specific
you know context of sufi metaphysics
essentially um but if there's interest
out there for a video about him then i
would i would definitely consider it
i have the translation of of insane
camel by
burkhardt
which is only translation of a section
of that book
but just that section those like those
sections are just really
really something
uh pantry warriors
i'm shia i watched your show video
and it was pretty good a lot more to
explore a lot more key details are
missing of course you know you make a
video about something like 12 ishii ism
how long was it like 45 minutes may seem
like a long video but when you're
talking about something that massively
you know deep and complex 45 minutes is
nothing like there's so much i could
have included and a lot of stuff that i
took out for various reasons
so when you're making a video like that
you really have to
narrow it down to to the basics and then
maybe a bit of a tangent here and there
but yeah there is a lot more that one
could explore in that tradition and i
probably will you know in future videos
but for that you know major video i had
to make some tough
cuts
smashing
smashing paper tigers asks if there are
any pre-secret philosophers you're
interested in making video on
uh yeah i would love to do one like you
say like promenities is really
interesting
so there's there's a sort of
a bit of a dilemma in my in my
mind over
what fits on the channel so i
have this other channel just which goes
under my name called philip palm in
which i post videos that i don't feel
like they fit on here so videos i just
made one on ziriab
the famous andalusian
musician
because that was not connected to
religion in any direct way so i choose
to put that on the other channel and
when it comes to philosophy of course
philosophy and religion and philosophy
and theology like the lines between
those are incredibly
blurry and unclear
so there are a lot of
ways in which you know i could talk
about these philosophy like pythagoras
there are clear parallels to you know
religious
you know mystery religions mystery cults
in that so that was a that was a an easy
choice when it comes to something like
promenities
someone argued that that's
that's just philosophy that's not
religion and of course like i said that
line is it's incredibly unclear
but you know after all i think my the
conclusion i came to was that you know
it's my channel i can do whatever i want
so if i want to talk about a philosopher
i'll just talk about a philosopher
but so parmenides is one of those
pre-socratic philosophers that i would
be interested in talking about
um
that's also the one that i know the most
about
and of course the the paradoxes of of a
student
whose name
weirdly enough
is escaping me
zeno right
anyway
so i want to do more stuff on greek
religion philosophy generally which is
why i started this sort of series with
this video on pythagoras i'm going to do
a video about
mystical experience in ancient greece
generally i want to do videos on you
know platinus and neoplatonism
uh
you know maybe the stoics who have
really interesting ideas about
you know the divine and religion
there's a lot of stuff to to explore
there
yes xeno that's right yeah that was i
was correct
jose gonzalez did zoroastrianism have an
influence on early islam
maybe i mean
zoroastrianism clearly had an influence
on all the abrahamic religions in some
way it seems that the sarasota ideas
you know crept into
judaism
in the
so around the turn of the the first
millennium there
a bit earlier perhaps
and then that
made its way into christianity and then
of course in into islam i'm not sure
that zerationism had a direct influence
on islam
you know in term like in the period of
the emergence of islam as a religion
after the prophet muhammad and so on
it's it's possible there are some i've
seen some theories about that and that's
interesting but i don't know it's hard
to say
some would say for example that you know
zerationism or zerations pray five times
a day which muslims also do
but you know
tons of other people also pray five
times a day it doesn't have to be a
direct correlation between those
to be us any plans on covering ancient
mesopotamian religion
uh i have an aspiration to do that
not any clear plans yet but because i
that's i you know in terms compared to
other topics that i talk about i don't
know
as much about that stuff
as i should in order to feel comfortable
making those videos that i will feel
like i know what i'm talking about
but i eventually i'll want to do that
yes
next week actually i'm doing
not next week but the next major video
next week is probably going to be a
video about um
well perguses
i don't know how you say it it's called
vol voice after in swedish it's a it's a
holiday
common in the sort of northern european
region
that takes place next weekend i'm going
to do something on that then the next
week and after probably
it's going to be a video about ancient
egypt which is going to explore
the concept of
one god so the concept of a single
universal god in ancient egypt
um
because usually we talk about egypt as a
polytheistic religion which is true
definitely and my video is nowhere going
to to to
question that
basic
idea but also explore the the
development of
a theology of
a single divine principle of which the
other gods are manifestations and so on
like that's the kind of thing we find a
lot of polytheistic religions in india
you know you have all the different gods
the deities and then you have the
brahman which is the divine principle
underlying everything then you have you
know in in an aztec religion in
the americas you have also again a bunch
of different theories but you have this
idea of the teot which is this
pantheistic monastic idea
of us of a
divine principle at the core of reality
in
greece
there is the idea of ho theos the god
often identified with zeus who stands
above the other gods so
polytheism
is a lot more complex and not as
different from you know monotheism
depending on how we define those terms
of course as many people tend to assume
sometimes and so in my that video i'm
going to explore you know can we find
evidence of that kind of idea of a one
god in egypt in ancient egypt that
should be really interesting
zevi is here
hopefully god willing one day we can
have
some tea together in person
but marcus
is inviting me to oslo for to do an ud
concert i mean sure why not
it's been a while since i did like
played a
gig or a concert basically since before
kovid happened so i'm a bit rusty i
think when it comes to playing live
so it'd be nice to to get out there
again and do some of that stuff
ibrahimovic do you know about ahmadiyya
i do i do there are some
communities of the ahmadiyya here in
sweden
i was planning on doing a video you know
visiting them perhaps
this was like years ago
it's been an idea a continuous idea for
years to do a video documentary style
about the ahmadiyya community here
so you know it could happen
daniel can you speak spanish i studied
spanish for four years basically in
middle school
[Music]
but
i
forgotten everything essentially
a lot of good questions i'm
there's a movie called man of man from
earth i'm sure i like it i haven't seen
it
i should i'll i'll
write that one down man from earth
what's it about
cake is healthy ask if i do fasting i
have done fasting
i've tried fasting on
various occasions i think it's uh
it definitely has its effects on you
i'll put it
that way
i've noticed some very significant
you know
well some significant effects when i
have tried fasting for different reasons
sanjika what's your favorite religion
not based on personal belief but on its
coolness okay
no i can't answer that question i don't
know i think all of them are cool
and if i did
answer that question
that would be
controversial not that i have a
controversial answer but just to have an
answer in general is and i don't really
i don't
i think there is a lot to be had
a lot of inspiration to be to be drawn
from from many different religions i
think they're all really cool in
different ways
mackery what's your thoughts what are
your thoughts on early jewish theology
would you say was monolithris rather
than monotheistic i tend to be
you know i don't know i'm not i'm not
i'm not a scholar or historian of
you know ancient
pre-exile
jerusalem or israel
um
so you know i would refer you to to
scholarship there but i tend to lean
towards the idea it seems to me
that
the israelite religion
was more like something
close to hinotheism or monolatry
and that it developed
into a more pure monotheism around the
the exile but i don't know
there are different perspectives on that
you know the bible itself of course
talks about
the fact that the israelites had
abandoned
monotheistic practice and started
worshiping other gods there's this
constant you know all the prophets
telling people that they had given up on
their true monotheistic ways
so who's to say that that's not also an
accurate account of what happened
i just i don't know
so pythagoras
i was going to say something a
pythagoras i forgot but
i should say that making this video
about pythagoras was really inspiring
and really
really fun i had a lot of fun making
that both the video itself you know
writing it i just think he's such a
fascinating guy
you know such a
you know i use the word weird in the
title
and cult which are both problematic
words
and
like i said in one of the comments i
responded to when the comments who
pointed that out like why do you call
that why they call them weird like weird
in
you know in relation to what and of
course weird
you know
and cults as well as a word that is
incredibly difficult to to use in a
proper way
many scholars have abandoned using the
word called altogether because there's
just
it's too difficult of a term
so the reason that those words are in
the in the video or in the title is
basically just to to sort of in a
lighthearted way
have an accessible title to draw people
in essentially
um because i felt in this video that
because pythagoras is not well he is
connected to some religions of course
you know the jews and the
some of those more um esoteric middle
eastern religions often have
often claimed to to have pythagoras as
an inspiration but nonetheless there is
no religion formed around pythagoras as
such and so
for that reason i
concluded that i could be a little more
light-hearted in this video because
there was less
chance of
offending someone and i wouldn't want to
do that of course and there are some
people who have
noted the you know that i make a joke
referring to the
late antique pythagoreans as the antique
hippies
just after pointing out the fact that
they you know have you know they smell
bad and i don't mean to say that hippies
smell bad of course that's not i was
just making a sort of
silly remark
i've
no hates against hippies i've been quite
a hippie myself in my day so
have you played assassin's creed
i have
and i think especially
um
[Music]
the the like the the last few ones
especially since assassin's creed
origins which took place in ancient
ancient egypt
the way that they have so basically
stopped playing those games for
for the the game itself and basically
playing those games because they have
recreated the ancient world in just such
an amazing
way
um
the way they recreated parts of ancient
egypt in that game and then the
following game was ancient greece
it's just incredible
uh
the amount of detail
and work they put into that stuff it's
it's fascinating and it's being used
they have that function in the game that
discovery i forget what it's called but
basically like it's basically an
education tool where you like walk
around in athens and then a voiceover
tells you historical facts and that was
almost my favorite part of that game
i think there's there's really a there's
i think there's
a future in in that in terms of
education that we can recreate worlds
that we are talking about and have
people sort of live in them and then
explore them while being
taught about those historical locations
that i am really excited about what that
could you know where that could lead in
the future
yes discovery tour that's what it's
called
what sparked your interest in islam
i don't know i've i've tried to answer
that question many times i don't think i
ever have a proper answer it's just
i've always been drawn to
middle eastern culture
uh
and even you know aesthetics and and
all
things related to that and
when i started studying religion
i was fascinated with you know middle
eastern history and so and islam is of
course a very central part of that
history and so that became
uh an interest for me because of that
it's also because when i started
studying religion i chose to
to to focus on islam
partly because and i this is again
something i've
said on multiple occasions but i felt
like
you know growing up with so many muslim
friends and and you know basically being
surrounded by people from all places
around the world as i grew up and then
you know
going out into the world and after you
know high school and so on and realizing
that there was so much misconception
and so many weird
opinions about islam that did not
correspond with what i had experienced
that i felt like you know it's a good
thing if there's more proper scholarship
more
you know people who speak about that
topic in an informed way
for people to
you know to get rid of some of those
misconceptions that are so prevalent in
the world i saw a super chat up here
al-ram thank you so much for the super
chat
i've seen lately a few videos about the
fatimid caliph al-hakim
what do you think about making a video
about this unusual part of islamic
history
i've been thinking about making
so i'm doing a video about
ismailism as i
mentioned and part of that will be of
course about the fatimids i'm been
considering making a video about the
fatimids
just in itself because i think that
dynasty is so interesting and that
hackim is one of the most central
figures one of the most famous caliphs
slash imams
uh
from that dynasty so al hackem for those
who don't know he was one of the fatimid
caliph imams which meant he was the he
was a caliph so the leader of the
fatimid empire but he was also the imam
so the central authority
and leader for the ismaili shiites
at least the ismailis who who followed
the the fatimids
and he's often called
like the insane
king basically
because he
seems to have
made some
peculiar decisions in terms of a rule
i think lately there has been some
you know so he would implement
laws that severely restricted the the
movement of women for example
and there has been some some voices
recently that has pointed out that a lot
of this is probably
not necessarily true at least the way it
is told is
often completely without
context and that there is a lot more to
al hackem than
what we often are told he is a very
fascinating figure also because he is
such a central figure in the
religion of the dhruvs
because
al hakem
you know being the ruler of an empire
being the imam the highest authority for
the shiites you know one day he just ups
and disappears
he lives in his palace in cairo
one night he
goes out for a walk he walks out the
gates of the city into the desert and
he's never seen again
which is just such a bizarre
story you know some say he died some say
he you know gave up on his life and
became an aesthetic or something
no one knows
uh and then he was succeeded by his son
and so on but
the the juice
which is uh
basically started you could say as an
offshoot of ismailism
holds al alhakam as a very essential
figure basically as a
you know um
i should choose my words carefully here
to don't i don't misrepresent their
theology but essentially he's he's seen
as a manifestation of god a
manifestation of god's light
i don't think
i'm not entirely sure
there's often a lot of misunderstandings
regarding those kinds of ideas that you
know they consider
different imams to be incarnations of
god and that's usually not what is meant
you know manifestation is more seen as a
kind of reflection of the light of god
and so on
anyway
so what hakken becomes the central
figure and central point for the jewish
religion in many ways
and he's also
aside from that he's just interesting
in himself
osman thank you for the super chat have
you read destiny disrupted by tamim
anzari i have not
i don't i don't think i've ever heard of
it even
so
if you want to tell me more what that
book's about that's
that sounds interesting i could just
look it up myself i guess
destiny disrupted okay
so i know there's a lot of questions a
lot of
comments here i'm not gonna
i don't have time to get to all of them
so i'm sorry that i'm skipping a lot of
you guys
the person who believe in an afterlife
i don't know and i think anyone who
claims to know is
wrong because they don't know
but
do i believe in it i don't
i don't know not necessarily an
individual like after that for the
individual i'm sort of
i guess i'm sort of taoist in that way
you know close to what the early taoist
would say of you know you are after all
just a part of the cosmos and the
of reality and you will continue to live
on as part of that totality but
maybe not an individual level but i
don't
don't know
okay what's your favorite kind of
triangle
um
i wish i had some
good
answer to that some funny
something funny to say but i don't sadly
uh
that's a good question
oh cool aladdin you're drinking tea so
so coffee versus tea seeker researchers
or tea wins every every time
every time
tea
you know tea
you know has compounds that make you
alert but also that calms you down so it
sort of calms you but it keeps you alert
coffee just makes you crazy
coffee just you know
make me hyperventilate and
vibrate
and it's bad for my stomach
i'm kidding of course if you like coffee
that's wonderful i i've enjoyed coffee
in my life too but i prefer tea
and for those who have joined
later i'm currently having some tea here
this is some
this is kimon tea from china a black tea
really wonderful wonderful tea
my favorite type of tea i don't i don't
know
i like a good oolong tea
like this one i'm drinking right now
which is a black one this is one of my
favorites
let's see
vincent
asks have you had greek mountain tea yes
i yeah i have
some early i have some herbal tree
herbal tea from from from greece
i can't remember the name of it but this
plant looks like a flower almost
it tastes quite nice
alvin
asks if i've ever been to the middle
east
so that's the crazy thing right i talk
about all these things i've studied
these so much
i don't think it i don't think you can
count that i've ever been to the middle
east like i've been to turkey i've been
to you know i've done field work when i
studied you know sufism at around field
work in the gambia and in senegal in
west africa
um
and i've been to the airport in morocco
but i've and that's not the middle east
either that's north africa
so uh no i don't think
i have been to the middle east
but i planned on going i was i was going
to go
this last winter but you know pandemic
stuff came came in the
way
got in the way
this
pesky
plague
that's been going around
now
um
asks me if i have ever
no yes if i've been to india no i have
not been to india
i have not been to india
but again you know there's no place i
wouldn't want to go
kind of i guess there are some places i
wouldn't want to go but
india is on my list of places i do want
to go to
cake is healthy ask if i've had any
mystical experiences
i guess so
nothing nothing
nothing crazy
but you know i've
i've meditated and i've had
not just in meditation but in other
circumstances i've had
interesting experiences
but i don't
that's not something i want to share
today i think
daniel
mihai highfield can you please explain
why god is one but still referred to as
him he
why the masculine annotation
i think there could be many different
answers to this one common answer so for
example in
um
in arabic
there is a pretty clear
etymological explanation because in
arabic there is no
pronoun for it
essentially right so the the neutral
pronoun is
which is he
um
and so so you're talking about god which
is of course
not
of any gender not a man or a woman
not masculine or feminine
you know to use the most neutral pronoun
at least in arabic would be to say who
which is
what is but but again if you read no
sufi poetry especially arabic sufi
poetry there is this sometimes they call
god by
her
or
various other pronouns to sort of
collapse that distinction both to
collapse the idea that god has a gender
but also
um
often you know when the sufis will talk
about
uniting or being annihilated in god they
will start playing around with pronouns
they will talk about
god as her
as
us
as you as he you know and just
switching between them
which is makes from some for some really
interesting poetry
um
genderless is a good word that i should
have used
when i was
trying to explain that yes
english is after all my second language
so give me a break
um
and and i think another
reason could be you know in other other
languages or whatever you know
masculinity or you know man as has often
played the role of a kind of
you know authority
has been you know men has been
associated with authority for a lot of
history
and so
god which is the ultimate authority you
know you know there are many different
reasons i think why you could
refer to god as as he not that you you
know
not that i think you should
but but why people have done that
but usually of course god the concept of
god is genderless
there are some
theologies and stuff that would
perhaps argue otherwise but
at least in a monotheistic sense right
if you talk about polytheisms you have
gods and goddesses and they have very
clear
roles
and sort of gendered identities
logo 2462 thank you for the super chat
have there been any notable islamic
missionary efforts
that did not include conquest
islam hasn't been
a missionary religion in the same way
that christianity has the ahmadiyya
community though which we have talked
about they do have some significant
missionary they do some missionary
activity
um some
you know
it does happen there's this i there's
this concept of da'wah
in islam which is basically missionary
activity
um so yes
i would say that
it is has been part of the history and
practice of islam but not to the same
degree of something like christianity
definitely
we have another chat here somewhere
super chat osman again thank you so much
destiny disrupted examines world history
through the perspective and the
evolution of the muslim community
sounds interesting
always good to have you know view
history from you know the perspective of
someone else than than you know a
european perspective which is what
what usually happens
there's a great book
by someone
i'm terrible at this because i forget
people's names there's a book
which explores the crusades
but from
the perspective of the muslims
essentially or the people living in the
middle east
which is you know surprisingly enough
not that much
isn't explored that much you know that
other perspective and what what happens
is that we realize that the perspectives
that
europeans had on the middle easterners
were exactly the same as the middle
easterners had on the christian
europeans that they were barbarians and
dangerous
more dangerous barbarians who came to
invade
it really puts things into perspective
when you read it from both perspectives
like that
if someone knows the name of that book
i think it's called crusades from
[Music]
from the muslim perspective or something
did i miss some other question here i
mean i miss a lot of questions
it was a good point vincent vincent the
west weren't there super preachers that
were in africa so yeah sufism and sufi
you know
have been incredibly central to to
spreading islam um you know as the
question and you know asked
in ways other than
which of course islam was rarely spread
as a religion arguably through conquest
because forced conversion has rarely
been a thing
even though it has happened of course
because the quran seems to clearly
argue against
forcing people to convert and so the
early muslim conquest for example were
not interested in converting people well
maybe they were interested in it but
that was not something that they they
did
in a forceful way
although you know of course you could
argue that there were circumstances that
appeared as a result of muslim rule that
sort of made things
that sort of pressured people in that
way nonetheless but
but in terms of spreading islam
uh in the more sort of missionary way
sufi sheikhs had been very important
in spreading it into anatolia for
example into west africa into india
and actually you know converting the
population that was
in some of these regions that was in
large part thanks to the to the sufi
sheikhs
thank you to
abba marcus very generous super chat
good
philip can i get your contact so we can
arrange for your visit to oslo hope you
stay here is it um
there is if you want to contact me i
have an email address on my about page
on on the youtube channel you can just
send me an email if you wanna
keep talking and gurjev and his teaching
[Music]
is something i wanna explore so
eventually i'm gonna get to the 20th
century i'm not doing videos in a
chronological order but
sometimes i do want to do things so semi
chronologically so that when i talk
about the 20th century
we have
a lot of the the background to
understand what was going on
during that century
i've seen that guy there's a guy this is
actually maybe good to point out there's
there's a guy
in
in the comments
who goes under my name so let's talk
religion and
basically
i don't know what he's doing he's trying
to
maybe posting some links so don't
if if you get a message from me or if i
respond to comments look for the check
mark beside my name you know the little
blue
or gray check mark if that's there then
that's me
you can trust that
if it's not then that's someone else
that's an imposter
and don't don't click on on his links
or hers
thank you
ayad for pointing that out
i
[Music]
i'm starting to pronounce everything in
arabic because i'm reading so much
arabic nowadays um
through the song keep making great and
interesting videos thank you for the
super chat and for the very kind comment
dw thank you for the super chat any
advice on depression
maybe from a religious spiritual view
and if there are any religious work that
might be insightful for depressed folk
this is a it's a difficult question and
i think it i don't want to be
irresponsible by giving some uninformed
answer to that i think
a good option is always to to talk to
professionals about that
if one is going through depression i
know that
for a lot of people
meditation works well
i know that it helps me and a lot of
other people when it comes to anxiety
and stuff like that
um depression is of course a different
thing
so the one advice i can give i guess is
that it's not very spiritual but i think
when you are when you become depressed
you have a tendency to avoid
things
because you you're like you know i'm you
know i don't feel like doing all the
things that i like doing
but i think
even though you should listen to your
your body and if you feel like you don't
have the energy to do something you
shouldn't of course rest but if you're
feeling depressed i think you should
also make an effort to
do the things that you enjoy doing
you know spending time with friends
um
whatever it is you like doing if you
know you like
playing music or you like playing video
games or whatever it is
um do that even though you don't feel
like doing it because if you do it
there's a you know that's still going to
give you
how should i put this
it helps right you it's better to do
things you like and be depressed than to
be depressed and not do things you like
and it does
help you recover sometimes alongside
things like
eating healthily and exercising and
getting proper
you know going for walks things like
that that's the very basics
and then on top of that
there's a lot more that could be done
but those are the basic things that
everyone says of course i'm not being
original here in any way but i think
those are always important things
thank you
fun
fun ambulance for the super chat
seek a researcher do you drink and smoke
i don't i've never
i never drank alcohol and i never smoked
i think i was i was telling uh zevi and
justin we were having a chat the other
day i was telling them i probably i
never had time to i was too busy
you know watching movies that was a
movie buff i'm still kind of but
especially in my like early teens i was
watching a lot of movies i was making a
lot of music playing a lot of music and
writing actually like writing
screenplays i would i would write
[Music]
screenplays for movies and
things like that
um i think i was just so uh sort of
absorbed in my
people call them hobbies i don't like
the word hobby but i was absorbed in my
interest in things that you know my my
passions
music and stuff like that that i was
never interested in
you know going out to to the parties
with my friends
so i just i never
was in a context where i was exposed to
that stuff
and then eventually you know i just
i never started drinking
and eventually i kind of liked
the fact that i didn't drink not that i
looked down on people that drink i think
they're you know
but i just myself
i like the idea of not drinking alcohol
i like to stay sober
logo 2462 what movies have influenced
you strongly so the movie that that
really got me into movies in the
beginning was when i watched the
godfather when i was 13.
again not a very original answer but you
know it is a very good movie
um
but i don't know there are a bunch of
films that are really cool i've been
the last few years i've been really into
the work of nasir khameer
he was a tunisian filmmaker he has a
film called baba aziz
which is
which quickly turned into one of my
favorite films of all time
it's about
this old dervish who
takes his grandson grandson along
to walk basically across
iran like the desert to find
like a sufi gathering
it's a beautiful beautiful film
life of pi is a great film
name of the iranian movement it was baba
aziz
it was made by tunisian
director but it it's it's uh it's in
persian
and it takes place in persia
he has other movies also he has one
called el haimuni
the wanderers of the desert i think is
the english title which was his first
film in that series
um and then he has one called
the ring of the dubs so the title is
based on the work by evan hasem the um
the ring of the the ring of the dove
basically and that movie takes place in
like medieval and lucia also very
beautiful that movie is in arabic and
i would recommend all these films
yeah the grand budapest hotel muhammad
abbas that's a
great one i used to be really into wes
anderson i haven't seen one of his films
in a while but that's the grand budapest
hotel is one of the one of the better
ones definitely
he has a really interesting unique style
which has almost become
you know
i forgot what i was going to say
it's such a it's such a
he has such a style of his own that it
almost becomes too much nowadays because
it's like oh he's just doing his thing
again
but i shouldn't be too harsh on wes
anderson i really like his his work
henry favreau
asks if i think buddhism in advaita
vedanta influenced each other
i i would say so definitely i think
when we look at some of the early
figures in advaita vedanta you know
shankara is the famous famous one but
there's
the one before him which supposedly was
his teacher's teacher
which is
what's his name gaudapada
when you read gaudapada where you read
his karaka for example on the the
manduki upanishad it's clear that he is
influenced in some way by buddhism
and that makes its way into advaita
vedanta that's at least my
read of it and then i think
according to many scholars as well
and then of course
the other way around is also possible
that
advaita vedanta influenced buddhism it's
inevitable that
religions and and philosophies influence
each other if especially if they're in
close proximity like that
that's always going to happen
afan sheikh bye bye
hope you have a good rest of the day
thank you all for showing up by the way
i'm not going to be streaming for that
much longer
it's 11 o'clock here so i need to go to
bed i gotta go to work tomorrow
but i'll keep talking to you for a
little while
have you read the
chemistry of happiness the yeah the
alchemy of happiness by al ghazali parts
of it i haven't read the full thing
but i've read parts of it
there's a section that's the one that
has a section about fasting right
which is where i
took some of the quotes
in my video about ramadan
thank you everyone for the very for the
very kind comments i'm glad you you
enjoy
the content
and you seem to really enjoy the video
that came out today
it seems really really appreciated and i
appreciate
that you appreciate
what i do
like i said it was a really fun
video to make
when will you get the so jacob britain
asks when we get the episodes on
platonism and neoplatonism so
neoplatonism definitely is coming
platinus
is one of my favorite philosophers
probably
so i'm going to do a video on platinus i
don't know when i have a couple of other
things planned now i'm doing the video
on on
valpargus night next week and then i
have the video on
uh god in ancient egypt the week after
that then i'm doing some stuff on
salafism i think
i might be doing a video about uh the
conference of the birds the great sufi
masterpiece by atar
which because i've been reading that
again lately and uh that's inspired me
to just make a video about it because
it's such an incredibly beautiful work
if you haven't read the conference of
the birds
then do it
there's a i've been reading a
translation by um
oh no not again i forget like this one i
gotta look up wait
so the conference of the birds
yes here we go the translation i've been
reading is by
no
so it's a poetic translation
the translator in question has attempted
to
make the translation rhyme
in english just like it would rhyme in
the original persian
it's in the penguin classics series
i'm almost there hold on a second
is it the one by afkam
darbandi
and dick davis
i think so
yes afghan darbandi and dick davis so
it's in the penguin classic series
conference of the birds it's a beautiful
translation
to the conference of the birds i'm going
to spoil it for you
not the entire thing the conference of
the birds is a classic of sufi poetry
and one of the great classics and
masterpieces of persian literature
is written by faridudin atar who is a
12th and 13th century
sufi from nishapur in persia
and he writes this work
called the
[Music]
the speech of the birds or the
conference of the birds which tells the
story of
uh
a group of birds so thousands like all
the birds in the world they gather to to
discuss who's going to be their king
and one of the birds the hupo who
becomes their leader says that we should
go find this uh great bird called the
simurg
and he will be our king but the journey
to simura will be very difficult you're
gonna have to cross seven valleys uh not
all of you will make it but in the end
you know the journey will be worth it
and we'll have we'll reach our king and
this is uh and i'm not gonna spoil the
end because it's just breathtaking but
it's uh
it's essentially a just a metaphor for
the sufi path you know the spiritual
path and sufism
photon asks if i eat pork i don't eat
pork because i'm
mostly a vegetarian
in swedish
there's a term called flexitarian
i don't think that works in english but
it's uh you know i i
eat vegetarian you know a vegeta
you know vegetarian diet most of the
time but you know if i
if i'm if i'm visiting someone and
they've they've cooked at dinner with
meat i'll eat the meat
it's the it's the buddhist buddhist
principle essentially i guess
henry favreau do you kind of serious
question do you think there can be some
kind of similarity between islam and
hinduism there's been a clash between
these two i mean i think many hindus and
muslims in history have thought so
i made a video on
dara shoko last summer who definitely
was one of those people he conceived of
islam
as understood through sufism and
hinduism
which wasn't necessarily a
word a term back then but
the the monotheists of india
so-called
which were basically like people who
followed advaita vedanta and so on
he saw them as essentially having the
same message
of this
one divinity that is the essence of
reality and that you know one can
become you know annihilated in this god
so there are many you know there are
definitely parallels that can be drawn
but we should also keep in mind the
diversity of the religions individually
there are many different interpretations
of islam there are many different
interpretations of hinduism and some
interpretations of islam can
work really well and and marry really
well with certain interpretations of
hinduism but other interpretations of
islam
will be very difficult to
to to find a sort of a synthesis with
certain interpretations of hinduism and
so on so it's a complicated topic but
there are definitely comparisons to be
made and many muslim thinkers and
you know hindu thinkers in history have
have considered that too
and what do you think of the idea thanks
for the super chat by the way what do
you think of the idea of the karmations
being communist i've never heard that
before
i've you know ever you know the
condemnations were the karma they were
essentially a
branch of ismailishism you could say in
the early muslim community
who sort of started a
revolutionary movement
it is said that they stole the black
stone and the kaaba in mecca for example
um
[Music]
you know when i've studied that movement
there's been nothing to suggest you know
i've never studied that and thought you
know this sounds like communism
so
but if there's any other
you know
scholarship or perspective on that that
i haven't
encountered that would be really
interesting to
to explore
joshua benjamin is
telling us
no one has ever proven any god to exist
neither can you i never claim to that
you know that there is a god
or that uh i can prove that there is a
god
i only talk about what what people
have said
but you know theology would often say
that god is not something
that is in the realm of being proven at
least not proven in terms of
how we conceive of proven as
scientifically or intellectually proven
you know god is often seen as something
that transcends
any such
conceptions at all
do i like schwarma
i do
but schwalma usually has meat in it and
so i will eat abstain but i guess there
are vegetarian variants
so the answer is yes
shawarma is good
what time is it okay
so my t's i still have some tea left but
it's basically gone cold
still good though
it's very cold
thank you zebi for showing up
i'm glad you
blessed us with your company and good
luck with the edit look forward to the
next video on maimonides everyone check
out seekers of unity
uh
zevi a good friend of mine he's
currently doing a series on
maimonides which is incredible he
masters that subject and it's really
just like it's such a
inspiring thing to watch those videos
and just see someone who is so
knowledgeable and who knows the topic so
well just do his thing
so go watch that series by by zebbie
seekers of unity is the channel
i also saw el moredom in this chat
before forgot to say hi if you're still
there then hello
good to see you
we should work together again soon
scanning for questions
that's why
there's silence
there's so many questions that i can i
kind of
become blind
i'm blinded by the amount
of comments here
i should eat black eyed peas a lot
miles helms says i wouldn't watch your
channel if you paid me but you're here
and i haven't paid you
so what are you doing here
okay ask what gives you a subtle joy
tonight while of course drinking my tea
and speaking to you lovely people
is a wonderful way to spend the evening
i think
i'm not sure this is very entertaining
for you but i sure enjoy
answering your questions
do you think ash ali doctrine is the
strongest i don't really have an opinion
i think
all different schools have good points
to make
gigi caffeine before bed that's a good
point actually it's a bit late to be
drinking
[Music]
tea
but it should be fine it's not coffee
after all
let's see
[Music]
i also have some chocolate here
i'm gonna
heat up your chocolate
cake is healthy wise
sorry why is pork forbidden in islam
honest question i think
i think the basic answer to that
question is because it says so in the
quran
it probably comes from judaism
originally
and there have been many theories
regarding why
that prohibition appeared to begin with
i think you and maimonides speaking of
which had a theory about that
but there's i don't think there's any
consensus
as to the actual reason
karen b do all religions instill fear of
hell no because not all religions
have hell
a surprising amount do though
like buddhism has a conception of hell
nothing of course very different from
the christian conception of hell and
muslim conception of hell but
but not all religions even have that
kind of idea even early you know
israelite religion
you know what we call judaism didn't
have hell
or paradise they had this thing called
sheol
it's really interesting i think andrew
from religion for breakfast has a cool
video about like the history of hell
he i think he covers that really well in
that video
georgios
polacis asked who is the most handsome
religious figure
that's
a good question
well do i count as a religious figure
other than that i don't know
only uh
only abdulx hey philip what do you think
the world would be like if there were no
religions
boring
now i don't know i think
i can't conceal a world without religion
because i defined religion so broadly as
a kind of human um
tendency to create
meaning through social identity and
bonding
and
using symbols to represent that so i
have avoided their kaimen conception of
religion as you can tell but
i just think that's such a
major part of the way that humans
function especially in group
that i just cannot
imagine you know what what else would we
do
i think the same
impulse
shows itself in in ways that most people
wouldn't define as religion
so you know different ideologies
also look very much like religions you
know and we we find new ways
of of feeding that impulse that don't
necessarily have language speaking about
gods or
things like that you know the words
change but i think the same impulse in
the same
aspect of human nature is being
fed in different ways
i'm not of the opinion that you know if
there was no religion there would be no
war anymore that's a very common thing
for for people to say i think uh not
only does that hugely
underestimate or sort of
misunderstand i think what religion even
is but it's also incredibly naive in a
way
um because like i said i think the same
impulse it doesn't have to be talk about
gods you know a lot of people is like
well religion is belief in god well it
doesn't have to be that
you know the same impulse can manifest
itself in different ways
uh we saw in the 20th century a lot of
very destructive
ideologies
that functioned like religions but
wouldn't count as religions to most
people so
i don't think there would be any any
difference in terms of that stuff
you know wars and violence without
religion have you read jahili poetry yes
and all those classics of course
in arabic also
because
unlike persian actually do
know how to read arabic
not well
you know i need that lexicon next to me
and i need to read slowly and like but i
can do it which is a great way to to
appreciate the poetry
i've also been reading uh you know ibn
arabi's through manila
lately
also in arabic there's a great
translation came out last year by
michael sells which has parallel pages
so arabic and english
that's perfect
for
[Music]
both being able to more quickly
interpret and understand but also
appreciate the original language and the
meter and the rhyming and all that
the melody
so i you know now
for that reason
i want to learn so many different
languages i want to learn persian so i
can read that porch i want to learn
chinese i want to
so
greek would be cool
hebrew also yes
i've been i've been sort of on multiple
occasions i've started studying hebrew
and then just
just sort of slipped
around to sunden someone says
the swedish term
basically just disappeared into the sand
latin is cool
uh you know
italian is cool you know we want to read
dante and italian that would be cool
secret researcher what are your views on
unitarian universalism
it's an interesting
movement
for those who don't know universal
unitarian unitarian universalism is a
christian movement
that's basically non-trinitarian which
is why it's called unitarian
they sort of reject the idea of the
trinity in christianity sometimes they
also
kind i reject
you know correct me if i'm wrong here
but i think not all of them but i think
some of them also reject the divinity of
jesus and see him as a prophet
much like you know muslims do or
some of the early christian movements
so
i think they're interesting
how did you learn arabic i studied
arabic so i
you know i started learning through some
apps years ago
um started reading
and then i studied arabic at university
for a year
and i i want to keep going with that
with those studies but other stuff came
in the way you know work and things like
that but
i'm gonna i want to keep going with my
studies because i know my arabic is is
you know you might think my
pronunciation is good because i've had a
lot of time to practice my pronunciation
but
in terms of my vocabulary that that's
still at a very basic level which is why
i need that lexicon all the time
so i really i wished my arabic was
better than it is
but you know
god willing in the future i'll i'll
i'll be better
as cow in your 12 or she is in video was
there any evidence that the 12th imam
not he ever existed i have read from
secular academic historical analysis he
never exists there are some theories
that he
didn't exist i can't really speak on
that i know that some even some early
figures around that time
also were skeptical if he was a real
person
but i also don't see any major reason to
to
doubt it um
again i don't
i haven't uh delved deeply into that
question in particular so i can't give
an informed answer
but i know that that has been a debate
how long have been going now
oh god an hour and a half okay i should
be wrapping up actually
yeah i should be wrapping up i should go
to bed soon
thank you all for showing up it was
lovely
speaking to you again having some tea
with you
great to see so many of you here also
some of
some of my
veteran
[Music]
subscribers here and some good friends
also showed up in the chat
i really appreciate all of you i
appreciate you
coming back watching my videos that you
support me
that you for some reason think it
interesting to listen to me just sit
here and talk for an hour and a half
which i just do because i enjoy it and i
don't fully grasp by why you would enjoy
it but i am humbled by the fact that you
seem to do
so thank you
um there is a lot
of exciting stuff coming soon i
mentioned some of them earlier and i
look forward to doing more streams like
this
uh
maybe in connection to future releases
also check out um
the video on pythagoras that came out
today i think it turned out really cool
it was a very inspiring and fun video to
make
and it's a
just such a fascinating topic
don't also forget to check out the let's
talk religion podcast which you can find
on spot spotify and all these different
places where you find your podcasts
we're in the process of releasing all of
my videos
in audio form on that podcast
so we're basically releasing two
episodes per week now so usually on
tuesdays and fridays
and we're uh we've gotten pretty far
it's still some ways off until we're
caught up with the videos but
check that out
uh my lovely wife is is doing most of
the work on that she's converting them
to audio form she's sort of
cleaning up the sound and all that just
doing a great work
uh great job
um
and uh
also look forward to more music
some of the background music that you
hear in the videos are going to be
coming out as an album this summer
uh and now i'm just doing a
self-promotion i'm sorry uh
thank you everyone for showing up uh
good night or good morning
or whatever time of day it is there i
hope you have a wonderful rest of the
day and the week
and i'll see you in a future video in a
future live stream
thanks everyone